A couple of weeks ago, we got an e-mail with a video in it...
...of a self-piloted, waterproof drone.
Would we like to see it work?
You bet.
Antoine Balaresque is a 24-year-old software engineer and roboticist...
...who invited us to Central Park so his quadcopter drone called "Lily"...
...could take pictures and video of us.
The Lily camera is, for the first time,...
...the camera flies and autonomously follows you around...
...and getting great shots and footage of your life.
The promo video looked amazing.
What I look as cool is the people skiing down the slope in slow motion or even cooler.
I'll never know because the footage never came out.
I assume I looked fantastic.